so as usual you begin with what you know
and what I know is the domain now that's
a really good place to start in this
example because look the structure of
the domain that you're restricted within
looks very much like what you're trying
to prove like this is less this is less
than that right so that's a good clue
for you right so here's my proof I begin
with this and I know it to be true so
now I think about what I need to do to
build on this and make it more
complicated to get to here which I know
is not the way we usually do but it's
not that hard and not to break away so
easy for what what's the very first
thing you would do to everything you
would square good and you always have to
do this between every line does squaring
because squaring you gotta be careful
with does it muck around with any V
inequalities do you lose any like
endpoints boundaries to the inequalities
change direction so far were pretty safe
because this is all you're worried out
that's variable there's nothing else to
deal with it okay so now what might you
do as your next step you could go in a
fugitive directions right personally I'm
going to do this I'm going to multiply
everything by minus one okay
now like I said there's many different
plans from here to here you might not
like the idea of reversing the
inequalities and actually it's not nice
to write it like this because actually
this means that t-square is outside but
as you'll see in a second theater car
isn't going to flip back the way that I
want them to okay so at this point I've
got a minus T squared why do you think I
did that
why do you think I went in that
direction it's because I have a minus T
squared here that's what I'm working
toward
okay so to get from here to here my next
step would be I guess I add four to
everything okay for here for here what
the companies do oh yeah that's right
yeah
that becomes a to i-94 every every part
in equality so that's a good all right
now can you see what I'm about to do
right I can divide through here what
should I divide through by it because
remember I flipped all the inequalities
bad quits right well I can flip them
back the right way if I take reciprocals
of everything right mm-hmm
this becomes a quarter this becomes 1
over 4 minus T Square and this becomes a
ha
clearly you can see now I've gone the
other way that look my big numbers over
here and my smaller numbers are over
here right so this is now the direction
of my inequalities okay I'm very very
close to what I need
look I've got my 1 over 4 minus T
squared there your the difference is I
needed 2 T squared there I can multiply
through everything my 2t squared why is
that because 2t squared is positive
right so I'm just going to go ahead and
do that
2t squared over here that will leave me
with T squared - in the middle here I
get what I expected and over here
I also get what I expected but then you
look at this a big hmm it's not quiet
it's not quite right this is something
wrong over here right this I want this
to be 0 but that's the problem is it
here's the way that I would lay it out
you could do this a couple different
ways I think this is the simplest T
suede on 2 is positive right it's
positive so therefore what I'm going to
just pop every here is well 0 must be
less than that and that's less than that
that's doesn't that okay I think this is
the easiest way to do it rather than
break out over here and safety square
it's greater than zero and so on I just
keeping my main the main body of my
argument so if this is bigger than this
which is bigger than this then this is
bigger than all of them right and so I
can cut this way out if you like like so
and that gets you to this result
so when you have a look at part 2 there
are some clues for what direction you
have to go in the first clue is that you
see now don't worry about what variable
is X's T's whatever you had X cube on 3
or TQ con 3 if you like right now you
can see where how would you get T cubed
on 3 from T Square and the answer is
integrated and you're confirmed by that
way you think oh there's a log in here
clearly that crept in because of some
integration right so that's kind of your
clue for where you would go from there
let's try let's try so here's where I
begin you all identified correctly good
work this is actually what I took out
and this is what makes a question hard
up in order when you're looking at HSC
questions right I could make this
question easier for you and therefore
place it earlier in the paper and make
it worth less marks if I held your hand
a little more right in between here here
there is actually a step right that
makes a little more obvious or they
could even tell you you should get to
here too from here to here by
integration okay but you you've seen
nothing equalities to recognize no no
clearly there must be something going on
right but the connection between this
and this is not obvious right and you
must settle it not just for yourself but
for the sake of your proof right so for
example you have a look at this middle
part here right I'll put it over here if
you've got this right how is it that
this came from this so if you're going
from here to here by integrating then in
order to think backwards then you would
be differentiating right now what's the
quickest way to get from there so
thereby differentiate well I just slap
this on the front if I ask you if this
had nothing to do with inequalities
right and you just had to differentiate
that what would you do I'll be the first
thing that you do you should take care
of the log right because gross look at
the chain rule you're gonna get from
there right you're gonna have to pull
that question it's gonna be a mess right
stead you must remember always
manipulate algebra first before you
differentiate or integrate or anything
like that so you can break this a cub
with your log walls right so you get
this minus this and there you could
differentiate it's not so bad so what
are you gonna get you'll get 2 over 2
plus X for this double negative so
you'll get 2 over 2 minus X from this
and you get to this okay
and now you the cogs might started
turning you can see where this is going
to come from what's this what's its
relationship to them it's yeah that's
right this is its partial fractions
really this is the difference of squares
right so you can simplify this a little
bit I can tip yourself that you end up
with 2x squared on 4 minus x squared
okay because that's a terrible form
because things cancel out quite neatly
on the numerator okay so so far so good
so therefore if you're gonna get me
Dakini fine you integrate but there's a
problem
I will very quickly show it to you right
if you just integrate this right was I
this rather you've got 0 d t t these are
all T's right now when you integrate
zero with respect to t you know that you
don't get 0 right well you might but you
don't know that you might what would you
really get you get a constant right and
this is kind of important not at least
the constant here but here and here
integrate with an indefinite integral
and you'll be stuck with the closer and
this is crucial to the proof so think
think what is a way to get rid of a
constant what is the only way to
integrate with noted constants answer
you need a definite integral of some
kind that's the only way to get rid of
constants everywhere so that you have to
think what would be a convenient thing
to choose but will be convenient
boundaries to choose that would give you
a constant over here right or would
eliminate all these concerts but lead
you to these X's
and based on what you got I think you
would have to integrate from naught to X
we looked at this under motion right
when sometimes you go from some nerd
value like two up to V or something like
that which is unknown right so you need
to think of these guys not just as all
right they told me to go from here to
here but there are tools that you can
use to get a result that you want right
okay so now let's hit play if I
integrate everything with respect to T
from naught to X okay I'll start with
the result I proved in part one he's
punching okay integrate everything from
naught to X with respect to T from
naught to X with respect to T and one
more time
like so okay so as we show it over here
right really this thing in the middle is
going to be this so when you integrate
that right as I'm trying to do here what
you're going to do is you're going to
climb that up to here which you can put
together with Loblaws like so okay so
therefore this side is going to be calm
well I mean you can think about it like
this but it's gonna be a constant - a
constant right up here you're going to
get from you're going to get this line
from naught to X don't forget at this
point I'm still all in terms of T's
because that's what I integrated with
this printer but once I sub in all of my
boundaries these will all disappear will
collapse okay and then what have I got
over here t cubed from 1 to X ok so once
you stop everything in you do have to be
careful with this thing because it isn't
show proof right but eventually it will
be nice and neat you'll get your 0 over
here you'll get your where am I trying
to go you'll get these guys 2 plus X 2
minus X and this too you become an X you
don't have to worry about the zero
boundary or disappear right by the way
if you're wondering yes where it's just
a constant so it's cost that minus
constant right so become zero yes this
is not it's not C times T it's just
C I mean if you want to think about it
this way right what are you integrating
you're integrating you're doing this
what's that line look like it looks like
this and you're finding the area under
the curve between 0 and X and that area
happens to be 0 okay all right and then
over here you get your X cubed on 3s
requires